hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
the fight to over fossil fuels
campaigners are already warning the next
Global Summit might fail to reach a deal
on phasing out coal and gas
the government scrapped a vote on
planning rules after dozens of
conservative MPS publicly threatened to
Rebel as they try to protect Greenfield
sites
in developing a green future as the red
car blast furnace makes way for one of
the UK's first carbon capture and
storage sites
foreign
[Music]
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis
now environmental campaigners and think
tanks say they are concerned about the
prospects for a deal on fossil fuels at
the cop 28 climate change Summit one of
the biggest issues under discussion is
how much help is needed for small and
developing nations to adopt renewable
energy despite calls for an
international deal to speed up that
transition there was no agreement in
shamal Sheikh and now there's concern
there might also be no deal at cop28
which is due to take place in the United
Arab Emirates in a year's time so let's
speak to Alden Mayer who's a senior
associate at the e3g environmental Think
Tank Alden thank you so much for talking
to us so one of the big things that came
out of cop27 was the number of oil
lobbyists just how many were how many
more were they at cop27 and at cop26 and
why is that an issue
well there were over 600 uh fossil fuel
industry Representatives according to
ngos that were tracking this that was up
from cop26 and of course they were not
there to advance climate action and cut
emissions and get us off of fossil fuels
far from that they were there to block
language in the text that would do that
as well as to make trade deals around
the side particularly trade deals
between African countries and Europe to
try to accelerate exported natural gas
to displace Russian gas a lot of people
have said that they are concerned about
the influence that oil producing
countries are having on these talks just
how concerned are you about that and how
much of an influence do they actually
have
well they've had an influence since the
beginning of this process in 1991 the
Saudis the kuwaitis Iran and others have
done everything they could to block
action on climate change matter of fact
in Glasgow last year at cop 26 it was
the first time that any fossil fuel had
been formally mentioned in a co-op
decision as needing to be phased down
and of course that was restricted to
Coal the oil and gas Lobby kept that
from being expanded to include gas and
oil as well
is this problem do you think the fact
that cop is a un Summit and so we look
at cop and see the influence they may
have and it's just a reflection that
they have at the U.N
well the cop has some good attributes
it's the only Forum where the vulnerable
country is the least developed countries
other smaller countries really get a
seat at the table and can use their
moral influence but of course the Saudis
and kuwaitis since the beginning 30
years ago have blocked any decision on
super majority voting in the process so
it requires consensus which gives them
in a handful of others the ability to
block progress a lot of action is
happening outside the cop in the G20 and
the clean energy ministerial and other
spaces that gives me some hope but the
fossil fuel countries and lobbyists do
exercise disproportionate power within
the UN system
if you're looking at geography
geopolitics where this cop is a lot of
people are saying okay it's going to be
in the UAE that's a huge Gulf petrol
state
but cop 26 Cop 27 27 was at charmele
Shake A lot of these all producing
companies were there there wasn't much
change in what was said is it down to
the geography or is it down to the
influence do you think it's unfair I
suppose is what I'm asking for people to
say where it is is a problem
well it's it's both I mean it's
obviously the influence of the fossil
fuel Industries in countries around the
world in the run-up to these annual cops
that influences their position but the
presidency does matter the Egyptian
presidency worked overtime to keep the
option of expanding coal phase down to
include oil and gas out of the cover
decision in charmel shape I think the
UAE may have learned from that not to be
as untransparent as the Egyptians were
and the UAE of course hosts the
international renewable energy agency so
it's open to clean energy sources but
the king of the UAE did say the
beginning of the first week at the cop
that they intend to keep producing oil
and gas as long as there's an demand for
it so we'll see how they play the king
of Saudi
the king of UAE yeah
yeah but if you look at the UAE and
Saudi I mean they are putting a lot of
money into sustainability into working
to combat
uh climate change they probably would
say that that is quite an unfair
representation of what they're going to
do at cop28 and what they're trying to
do in general
well they have made some progress in
recent years on expanding support for
clean energy Technologies of course they
talk a lot about carbon capture and
storage which would allow them to keep
exporting fossil fuels it's not really
an economically viable technology for
large-scale use the real question is
they have been trying to block any push
to phase down production and use of oil
gas and coal as the intergovernmental
panel on climate change says we have to
do if we're going to have any chance of
coming close to the 1.5 Celsius
temperature limit okay Alden thank you
so much for talking to us
good to be with you thanks
now the government has postponed a major
vote on plans to build more houses after
conservative back benches threatened a
large Rebellion more than 40 Tory MPS
signed an amendment to the leveling up
Bill which would make it easier for
councils to ban building on Greenfield
land and provide more incentives to
develop Brownfield sites the former
environment secretary Teresa Villas has
said that without this amendment the
plans would encourage quote development
which damages the environment and
quality of life let's speak to our chief
political correspondent John Craig who
joins me now hello to you John so what
are the government's plans let's start
with that
well the very latest from the government
from astounding Street spokesperson this
afternoon is that that commitment uh to
build uh no fewer than 300
000 new homes uh targets by the
mid-2020s that commitment remains uh
says Downing Street uh they say that we
want to build more homes in the right
places and yet the government has
retreated uh following the threat of a
major Rebellion by up to 50 conservative
MPS now Teresa Villas a former cabinet
minister uh tabled a new Clause to Mr go
Michael gove's Flagship Bill the
leveling up and regeneration Bill and
her new Clause proposed that that Target
of 300 000 may only be advisory not
mandatory she was backed by all sorts of
senior Tory MPS John Redwood Maria
Miller Damien green Chris Grayling
pritchie Patel Esther McVeigh a clutch
of cabinet ministers there so whilst the
government appears to be in Retreat over
a vote that was due to take place next
Monday then that Downing Street is now
saying they remain committed to that
Target of 300 000. incidentally over the
past year the government's only Built a
172
000 so way short of that
okay John thank you so much
well also making the news today work on
what could be one of Britain's biggest
climate change projects are taking
another step forward the 365 foot tall
Blast Furnace at redcast steelworks was
demolished early this morning the site
will now be used for the Net Zero T side
project which aims to build one of the
UK's first large-scale carbon capture
and storage facilities taking greenhouse
gases out of the atmosphere and locking
them underground
Thames water have announced the hose
pipe ban imposed on 15 million people in
England is being lifted after three
months the company says the recent
rainfall and the Public's compliance are
reasons for removing the ban the
restrictions came into effect on August
24th after a drought was officially
declared across most of England
following the driest July for 50 years
Paris is considering a ban on electric
scooters after concerns around
pedestrian safety and questions over
their environmental credentials it was
the first city in Europe to open up the
scooter hire Market four years ago it
has about 15 000 of them for hire and
one councilor has said the vehicles have
turned Paris into a quote jungle
and more than half of the gas lamps in
London's West End will be saved after a
change of Hearts by local officials
Westminster Council had proposed to
convert 174 Street lamps from gas to the
more environmentally friendly LED
Heritage campaigners say the proposals
do not go far enough and claim they are
still fearful about the lamp's future
now if you have a question about climate
change that you want to be answered send
them all via this QR code QR code on the
screen and we will try to answer as many
as possible on the climate Show with Tom
Heap at the weekend and just a reminder
you can watch Tom's show on Saturdays
and Sundays it's at 3 30 in the
afternoon and then again at 7 30 in the
evening but for me Kimberly Leonard
thanks for watching for now and I'll see
you tomorrow
thank you